I've never had a character where I've  done such a physical transition before  one that required well initially I had a  hair makeup test with Tim in London and  we decided he knew that he wanted  something visually to be different than  past iterations so the bangs came into  play which he really really loved I  think that he liked it was kind of 60s  mystery detective so that was different  for me and then the black hair there was  a little bit more of a pale face and in  the black and white wardrobe it's funny  because I remember on the first day  looking in the mirror and not really  recognizing myself but then you do it  for eight months and by the end you're  just thinking get it off of me